hello and welcome to this video playing
ha ha chess no new work on it ok so II
45 he doesn't get it that often so it
has to think about it it seems yeah the
dalian to get some more and more popular
[Music]
also slightly three setups I check this
recently and it's really not clear what
blacks supposed to do it's um it doesn't
look like anything at all but somehow y
term has a slight pull in many many
cases
you usually they go Bishop e3 this is
one of the points
not that there's anything particularly
wrong with them at same 93 or something
maybe I have 90 in this case mysterious
oddity disconnect no a pretty bad
connection this person but yeah is not
disconnected looks like absolutely
nothing but I've lost those positions
quite often somehow it is not easy at
all
just going away from a possible b5 break
[Music]
should that be okay could have played I
could have played c6 first but still
should be okay takes 90 x 90 for maybe
but mm-hmm Queen f6 even could be on not
sure he's taking ages ready for this
position ok so do i go see six now
online I think I do so if she takes I
can just take with the pawn
so take or do I think I can deform that
space is quite tempting no actually
blundell age six but I think he cannot
take it okay check a bit lucky so he's
giving me the before porn think I've
take it I have Queen c3y I'm is my queen
trapped right let's I'm not that
Oh
it would look really stupid right but ok
quindi 14 91 491 that could work I don't
see how however how he wins the Queen
[Music]
doesn't do it yeah this I thought should
be okay piling up on the depot now look
you one night 64 so he has to go okay
three
[Music]
ok that's possible
[Music]
okay maybe I should have prevented this
move okay at least now we cannot play
Knight f3 all that easily d 4 threatens
to take one evil I actually does not
threaten to take this chair so I go for
that check
94 as possible you will get serious time
problems yeah no but I think and now
he's six no that's way too and the rook
and put them into that fork there is no
way how disappointing then it's not you
in that grade check check check good g8
convert
[Music]
time warning actually doing threatened
to do this hmm check check white resigns
his time management killed him in this
game yeah okay in the in the opening I
think there's really not much going on
it is this kind of situation which I
tend to lose against strong players
where nothing happens somehow and
install so why does a bit better yeah i
don't know i think here should be should
be okay check now yeah this was
interesting now he just give away before
I wasn't sure about this I thought 321
and was dangerous because my queen
doesn't have squares I had to I looked
at this and I didn't see a way for him
to trap my queen but it seems there is
no like quick way to do it as the engine
doesn't see anything but I still felt
this was the way to go this really is
better for black geo maybe ask wondered
some of the
bondage away taking and then looking
forward this is also pretty nice are
taking immediately check is also better
for black I mean I'd say that I probably
did not play it then well I was kind of
staring at the clock of childhood Chang
I will win and win on time check I think
I probably didn't do this correctly
might be that it is open anyway it is
check yeah the engine gives the win no
matter what you do is follow us too much
even for me to support it ok guys thanks
for watching